-Hello, everyone, and welcome
back to the attic.
Now, as some of you know,
I have been dealing
with a wasp infestation up here
while I've been taping the show.
There was even a flyby last
week.
It got so bad that I said to
myself,
"If there's a pest worse than
wasps,
I'd love to know what it is.
And lo and behold,
I opened
The New York Times on Saturday
to read "'Murder Hornets'
in the U.S."
Murder. Hornets.
Thank you for giving us the
uplifting non-COVID-related news
we've all been looking for,
New York Times.
Anyway, story gave me a whole
new appreciation
for my nonlethal wasps who I'm
almost certain
aren't murder hornets
in disguise,
although one of them keeps
telling me I'm pretty
and bringing me trinkets.
And based on every
true crime doc I've watched on
Netflix,
that is a red flag.
But to thank them for not being
murder hornets,
I have added a few of the wasps
to the writing staff,
which we think will help give
the show some good buzz.
I told you that joke was a dud,
Charlie.
Put your stinger away, Charlie.
Not today. It's Monday.
What?
Oh, Mondays aren't considered
bad by wasps?
Why's that?
Oh, yeah...
You don't classically have jobs.
Anyway, speaking of duds...
Segue!
...President Trump gave a town
hall on Fox News last night
as a damning new report details
how he's wasting time
he could've been using to
develop a strategy
for safely reopening the
economy.
For more on this, it's time for
A Closer Look.
President Trump beamed into
America's living rooms
last night during a Fox News
town hall
from the Lincoln Memorial, where
it kind of looked like
Lincoln had been asked to join
but was keeping his distance.
Now, obviously the interviewers
were practicing
social distancing there, but
it's more fun if you imagine
they all started out sitting
close together
and then just scooted their
chairs back a little
every time Trump said something
insane.
"Uh-huh. Oh, interesting.
So just...any...household
disinfectant will work.
That is... [straining] great
to hear."
And sure enough, Trump made it
awkward at one point
by pointing to the memorial and
complaining,
as he has before,
that he -- he has been treated
worse than Lincoln.
-I am greeted with a hostile
press,
the likes of which no president
has ever seen.
The closest would be that
gentleman right up there.
They always said, "Lincoln --
nobody got treated
worse than Lincoln."
I believe I am treated worse.
-You have two unfiltered
hours on national television
to say whatever you want
to millions of people
without fact checking or
follow-ups.
Lincoln couldn't even get
through a play
without being interrupted.
I'm shocked the memorial didn't
pull a Fauci.
And of course, as is his wont,
Trump rambled incoherently
about God-knows-what
for basically the entire two
hours
with virtually no attempt
at fact checking
or rigorous cross-examination
from the moderators.
I guess Lincoln wasn't the only
statue there last night.
As usual, the Fox moderators let
him lie freely
about a bunch of verifiably
untrue things
and in some cases, they didn't
even make him
answer the question he was
asked.
They were less like reporters
and more like the audience
in an improv show.
"[ As Trump ] Okay to get
started?
I just need a one-word
suggestion."
"Oh, uh, ventilators!"
"That's good.
I think ventilators will be
good."
Watch him totally lose his train
of thought
and wander away from a
question that was supposed to be
about the coronavirus.
-Do you think the election
will come down to a referendum
on how you handled this crisis?
-No, but it's gonna be a factor.
-Do you think it'll be
bigger than that?
-No. I think the election's
gonna come down to --
I hope it does because we've
done a great job.
We had no ventilators.
We had no testing.
We had nothing.
I had -- I inherited empty --
empty -- no ammunition.
Our military was bad.
We've rebuilt our military.
$1.5 trillion.
We have the best military by far
in the world.
It's rebuilt.
It's either all new
or the equipment's coming in,
which is great.
-What are you talking about?
Is someone shining
a laser pointer on the floor
that's distracting you?
You were asked a question about
the coronavirus,
and you said you inherited no
ammunition,
which is both not relevant and
also a ridiculous lie.
You expect everyone to believe
that when you took office,
soldiers were patrolling war
zones without bullets?
[ As Trump ] We had no
ammunition.
Whenever a soldier shot a gun,
a little flag popped out that
said, "Thanks, Obama."
[ Normal voice ] And then,
of course, there were
the typical nonsensical
Trumpisms
where he tries to make himself
sound like a tactical genius
but reaches for the
dumbest metaphor possible,
like when he was asked if he
would impose new tariffs
on China and said this --
-We're all playing a very
complicated game
of chess or poker.
Name whatever you want to name,
but it's not checkers,
that I can tell you.
-Oh, it's chess or poker?
You should probably find out
which game it is.
[ As Trump ] I see you've taken
my rook, but perhaps
these three Jacks will have
something to say about that.
And that something is Uno.
[ Normal voice ] So Trump spent
his Sunday night
embarrassing the Lincoln
memorial on Fox News,
which makes sense because he's
constantly
in a state of either watching
Fox or appearing on Fox
or watching himself appearing on
Fox.
Eventually, Fox is just gonna
turn into a 24/7 feed
of Trump watching himself on Fox
like an infinity mirror.
Trump also surrounds himself
with people he sees on Fox
from informal advisers
to White House aides,
like his newest press secretary
Kayleigh McEnany,
who held her first briefing on
Friday.
and McEnany's hiring very much
illustrates the feedback loop
of disinformation and propaganda
that exists between the Trump
White House and Fox News.
For example, in late February
and early March,
more than a month after the
first confirmed case
Of coronavirus in the U.S.,
McEnany went on Fox channels as
a spokesperson
for the Trump campaign and told
outlandish lies
about Trump's response to
the coronavirus outbreak.
-This president will always
put America first.
He will always protect American
citizens.
We will not see diseases like
the coronavirus come here.
-Let's turn it to your rallies,
the President's rallies.
Are you a little bit worried
about holding those kind of
rallies?
-I'm not, because we have the
added advantage here
at the Trump campaign that our
candidate happens to be
the President
of the United States.
-The President goes ahead with
holding his rallies,
his top doctor --
top medical guy -- says,
"Don't go with big crowds."
I mean, you're immediately gonna
be hit with this.
-Look, the President is the
best authority on this issue.
-I think what's going on
here is she's playing checkers
and the interviewer is
playing chess.
Or poker.
Not only is Trump not the best
authority on this,
whenever he's around actual
authorities,
they have to keep correcting
him.
My favorite examples of this are
when Trump pitches
insane coronavirus cures, and
the medical experts around him
have to politely tell him, no,
that's not a thing.
-Deborah, have you ever heard
of the heat and the light
relative to certain viruses,
yes, but relative to this virus?
-Not as a treatment.
-You take a solid flu vaccine,
you don't think that would have
an impact
or much of an impact on corona?
-No.
-Even the real housewives know
there's stuff
you talk about when the
cameras aren't rolling.
I mean, they have briefings
before they have the press
conferences,
and I bet they've begged Trump
to get his dumb
questions out then.
"Hey, before we go out in front
of the American people
and all those cameras, are there
any, you know, miracle cures
you want to ask us about now?"
"[ As Trump ] No, no, I had two
out there.
I got some good ones today."
Here's a hint --
hair spray and Altoids.
Who knows?
Who knows until you say it out
loud in front of the cameras?"
[ Normal voice ] In fact,
Trump's fixation
on miracle cure-alls and
shortcuts
is also reflected in a damning
new report
in The Washington Post
detailing a lost month
of desperation and dysfunction
in which he ignored
and then abandoned
the goal of actually beating
back the virus and instead
focused on prematurely reopening
the economy
without a plan to do so safely.
For example, The Post reports
that Trump was pushed privately
by political allies like
Rudy Giuliani and Fox News hosts
to embrace the drug
hydroxychloroquine
as a treatment for coronavirus
even though it was unproven and
potentially dangerous.
That's right,
hydroxychloroquine.
Remember when everyone cared
about that for a second,
the Tamagotchi of COVID cures?
Well, according to The Post,
night after night,
in late March and early April,
he kept hearing about the
controversial antimalarial drug
on his favorite Fox News channel
programs
where television doctors
and commentators
touted its efficacy.
Yeah, the TV President who
played a TV businessman
is listening to TV doctors like
Dr. Oz and Dr. Phil,
seen here getting an X-ray in
real time, I guess.
Oof, looks like he took
the President's advice
on heat and light.
Seriously, what's up with the
aggressive blue?
Looks like a spaceship had its
lights on in the parking lot.
This is what the TSA agent sees
on the monitor
when a normal person goes
through
the airport body scanner.
But there's apparently one
Fox host in particular
that has Trump's ear on
coronavirus issues
and has actually advised him
at the White House.
On April 3rd, Fox host
Laura Ingraham
paid Trump a visit
in the Oval Office
to talk up hydroxychloroquine.
She brought with her two regular
on-air guests
and what she dubs
her medicine cabinet.
On April 14, Ingraham returned
to the Oval Office
to meet with the President.
The Fox host reiterated her
belief
that the country needed
to open and argued for limits
on contact tracing.
So a Fox host with no medical
expertise
is directly advising the
President on a deadly pandemic
while that same President hires
pundits he sees on TV
and fires or punishes actual
experts and inspector generals
who criticize him.
This is what you get
when you make a TV star
President
because when you're on TV, no
one ever tells you you're wrong.
For example, no one ever thought
to tell me
that I should maybe buy a shirt
in a shade that isn't blue.
But that's what happens when
you're on TV.
90% of your agent's job is to
text you after every show
and tell you you're crushing it.
I mean, It's different for me
because, you know,
90% of the time I'm -- you know,
I'm crushing it.
But I meant for other people on
TV, it gives you
a false sense of yourself,
and in Trump's case,
I'm assuming he had an entire
team of producers on-set
to tell him his bronzer
looked realistic
and then air brush whatever
the hell this is
so he doesn't go on TV looking
like he went to the beach
wearing a football helmet.
And Ingraham's criticism
of the age-old public health
practice
of contact tracing is especially
worrisome
because it's one of the main
tools experts agree
we're gonna need to contain
this mess
and safely reopen things.
We have to test people
on a massive scale,
isolate cases, and trace their
contacts
to see where the outbreaks are.
Lots of other major countries
and several states
like New York are beginning to
do this.
And contact tracing is a thing
we've already done successfully
for decades for things like
tuberculosis, measles,
and sexually transmitted
infections.
And yet, during a segment that
Trump probably saw,
Ingraham and Trump's toothless
Dracula, Rudy Giuliani,
actually laughed at
New York's plan
to implement contact tracing for
coronavirus.
-Michael Bloomberg is gonna
handle the tracing --
army of tracers -- in New York,
we learned today.
-That's totally ridiculous.
-Yeah.
An army of tracers.
-Then we should trace
everybody for cancer.
-Yeah.
Army of tracers.
-We should trace everybody for
cancer and heart disease
and obesity.
I mean, a lot of things kill you
more than -- more than COVID-19.
So we should be traced for all
those things.
-Oh, my God, it's for
transmissible diseases,
you second-tier Jeff Dunham
puppet.
You can't catch heart disease on
the subway --
you know, unless you
accidentally step onto
an empty car and nearly have a
heart attack.
Oh, my God, what's that smell?
These are the people whispering
in Trump's ear
about a deadly pandemic.
And in cases like McEnany's,
they're the people he's hiring.
Trump apparently decided to
reward McEnany
for her blind loyalty by making
her White House press secretary,
And on Friday, she seamlessly
transitioned
from Fox News liar
to White House liar
by holding her first press
briefing
and making this absurd comment.
-Will you pledge never to lie to
us from that podium?
-I will never lie to you.
You have my word on that.
-Wow, she managed to
break her promise
before she finished making her
promise.
That's impressive.
It's like a Mobius strip
of bull-[bleep].
And then, sure enough,
McEnany completed
the Fox News feedback loop
by taking time out of her
first official press briefing
to advertise Trump's Fox News
town hall
and brag about his TV ratings.
-Everyone should watch
the Fox News town hall
with the President
from 7:00 to 9:00 p.m.
It'll be a can't-miss television
much like the highly-rated
President Trump
coronavirus task force
briefings have been.
-Oh, cool, so in the
middle of a deadly pandemic,
the White House press secretary
is like a glorified
TV Guide channel.
Looking for willful ignorance
from a soulless sociopath?
Check out the Fox News town hall
at 7:00.
Also, can we assume you're
watching
the TV Guide channel again
because you've finished
every show on every streaming
service?
In that case, welcome back.
The President spent precious
time rambling for hours
on state TV even as
The Washington Post
detailed the lost month of
dithering and disarray.
More than 65,000 Americans have
died,
and at least 30 million are out
of work.
What we're seeing yet again when
it matters most
is that Trump has the intellect
and emotional maturity
of a child flipping over the
table after losing...
-...a very complicated game of
chess or poker.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
Since this crisis started, we've
been asking people
to help City Harvest,
so please continue to give.
More and more New Yorkers
are turning to them
to keep food on their tables.
If you're watching this online,
please hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.